[Applause]
get it out get it out
I don't know why I'm shocked but once
again you look you you make something
casual very cool and rock and roll truly
you are a fashion icon yeah
and you're a fashion knockout so if you
always to fashion like even when you're
like younger I always I don't I was born
that way like just love just love
clothes love makeup love just I'm like a
visual person I guess I just see the
world through visuals but not everybody
sees like that not ever like me we are
opposite like I don't I didn't do any of
this I can't understand and um so I
don't see like that like and it's weird
For Me That You Don't See like that like
I'm like how how do you not see like
that I know that's just the way but it's
art it's like some people don't love I
just I've always been like a thrift
store Shopper like I just love it and I
came out looking different yeah I
shopped at thrift stores too Gwen but
like I didn't come out looking like this
I came out looking like she went to a
thrift store
um so it's very different
um but I love I love that it's all
organic for you I love that you have the
line that's so cool and you have like
your signature look that everybody loves
too that I think when I saw you on
Instagram you first came out it was like
your signature red like lip look that
yeah that was so cool and I for all of
us nerds were like you know we were like
yeah just a girl like you know back in
the day like you know what I'm saying
like and you think you were weird back
then but all of us were weird and you
made us feel like we weren't so that's
what was so cool about you anyway that's
all right but what
what we thought we'd run through some of
your past looks though to get the
stories behind them so is that okay yeah
okay okay so let's start with this one
from your no doubt days so where did
this look what were you thinking
it feels like yesterday I mean honestly
time just goes so fast it's crazy I mean
honestly back then like I said I didn't
have a stylist or a makeup artist and
once we started really getting on tour
like we basically did the just a girl
video right and it was our first video
really and went to the airport and then
I didn't come home for like two and a
half years like I we went on tour like
it was like bye like Mom will be back no
I'm not I'm and I still lived at home
and I was 26 so I didn't because I was
gone on tour but yeah all my stuff was
there and um so when we were on tour it
was like well after a while I needed to
close you know what I mean like I needed
costumes I would wear the same thing
over and over again everyone smiled like
it was like it was like I was super
unorganized makeup a bus with boys yes
yes disgusting it's different but those
actual pants I think that was one I
found this girl through my manager that
would just make clothes for me so like
she would go downtown she would send me
like literally a piece of paper with
like swatches stapled to it and I say
okay do these pants and I do it from the
road and then she would FedEx out a pair
of pants that was very home grown I know
I know but that's what I mean it's so
natural and then you had a line it all
made sense but I love that you look like
you're just so rock and roll like the
person that passes you on the street
that you're like man I want to look like
that and then you just walk on stage
like that's what I loved about this look
that was my input right there um but
wait what was what was the occasion here
I love this dress so much okay this is
so pretty that's Janina
oh wow thank you the designer is Yanina
um that was my first public date with
Blake Shelton actually yeah
um it was the Oscars Vanity Fair party I
think I played at the party and then we
went out that night wow it was like he
never does red carpets now that I know
him like yeah that was like we got I
think we did a red carpet it was it was
kind of a red carpet it was raining that
night and um yeah always like that melts
me when I see it because it's like such
a there's a memory for me yeah a good
one I didn't know that but you look like
Christopher lady in red like you're
walking in the room and the song was
written for you like that song back in
the day I just aged myself I love that
song so much
um okay so wait where was this shot
taken what about this one
look at that thank you
that's um that's Vera Wang
um it was at the Met Ball this year and
um she's just so talented Vera's been
doing it for so long and so to be able
to work with her yeah it was just
amazing to wear a Couture dress made for
me like when the sketch came it was like
it looked exactly like that like they
drew my face like the hair everything
and I just it was weird to go from a
sketch to like real life yeah and that
was one of those crazy moments where I
was gonna have a makeup artist do my
makeup and she her mom had an emergency
she had to leave so I luckily had my
makeup bag and did my own makeup that
night so it was one of those like crazy
moments oh my God it was exciting
but I see another difference between us
so you came out looking like that after
you did your makeup
a French for me I love you anyone can
because I don't um no I love that though
because I think that's the coolest thing
about fashion is sometimes we forget
it's such an art form and it's so
beautiful and you literally look like a
walking piece honestly I don't even
think people understand like these
designers are so talented and creative
and I walked into the room and they had
those flowers they have like hundreds of
them that they had made by hand like
deciding where they're going to put them
it was literally like in the Moment Like
while you're ready about to oh yeah it's
just to me like Beyond a dream to be
able to work with someone so gifted that
has had such an impact and you know Vera
has done so many wedding dresses and
yeah a big part of people a lot you know
people's lives with her vision so yeah
that was an amazing moment and never
thought that I would get to um I'm still
playing with that crop top ma'am bam bam
bam I like after three children whatever
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]